what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand Linux training where I get
together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using YouTube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their Brand This
Year enjoy
Channel analytics these are the basics I
had to cover up the basics because this
is something everybody looks at but
views watch times and Subs gain I don't
know a single YouTuber who doesn't look
at this on their Channel how many views
did I get last month how much watch time
did I get how many Subs did I get it's
not super informative because a lot of
times they're all connected
so if a video blows up for you it's
going to have lots of views it's going
to lead to lots of watch time and you're
going to get a lot of Subs from it so
it's not very very insightful but it's
good it's good just to have a high level
overview
um and if you if you have goals that
you're working towards most people's big
goals are tied to one of these three
metrics usually views are Subs because
you want to get that that plaque you
want to get that million subscriber
plaque or the 100 000 subscriber plaque
or it makes you feel good to say you
have 10 000 subscribers on your channel
but it doesn't really help us that much
in terms of making strategic decisions
this is more just many metrics that
people go after and it's just a good
General Benchmark Revenue though is
important so
for some of you Revenue might be a main
driver where you're trying to really
make a lot of money from the YouTube
channel and you want that to be the
thing that um
pays for everything and for some of you
you have a business that's attached to
it and you don't really care how much
revenue the channel makes you're trying
to drive app downloads or you're trying
to drive coaching sales you're trying to
drive book sales or your program sales
or whatever it is that you're trying to
sell so depending on where you're at
with Revenue this might be really
important or might not be but every
month I definitely recommend going in
and checking your Revenue tab
and what it'll show you is
quite often when you release a video so
look at this as an example when they
release a video the revenue spikes right
so video comes out Revenue pops each
time so my big thing here is hey maybe
we should release more videos if your
goal is to make more money off the
channel we should be releasing more than
whatever this is five videos in a month
the other really important thing to look
at here is top earning videos
so on their top earning videos it'll
show you recently right so this is past
20 days and you can I usually go 90 but
you can do it with 28. you see what's
popping right now on the channel not the
videos that did well three years ago if
you've been around that long but what's
happening right now and what what you'll
almost always find is there are
it's not even not the 80 20 rule it's
like the 98 2 rule like two two percent
of your videos end up driving 98 of the
revenue it's a pretty giant number in
comparison so even looking at this these
guys you know they've they made 4 500
bucks in the past 28 days their top
video looks like that's 400 is that 400
no 600 600 500 400 400 300 and then it's
going to be a big drop off
so you'll find that there are some
videos that just pay you super well
because they have a really high uh CPM
so advertisers care about this topic
and others they won't
and so that could guide content decision
so if revenue from advertisements are
something that really are important to
you we're looking at making longer
videos you know 10 minutes plus but
an hour two hours three hours if you
want
um and then really paying attention to
which videos are actually bringing money
in for you because inside every Niche
they're going to be these super specific
videos that just pop off really well for
you and so you look can I make a round
two of it so if monetization is really
really important to you then looking at
your top videos that earn money
and trying to make that into either a
weekly series or some 5 7 10 20 part
series for the channel if you have more
content to share on it one because it
pays well and two because you can show
up as suggested against those videos so
when somebody's done the first Harvard
video from Pablo and then they see that
there's more they're likely to click on
those ones as well so the first one's
making the money the second one's in the
third the third the fourth the fifth the
sixth Etc are gonna keep making him
money much more typically than your
average video
so if you're ignoring the revenue tab
there's so much you can dive into on
YouTube analytics I don't want to
overwhelm you and stress you out
but I'm here trying to give you the most
important ones to pay attention to that
I would do if I were you on a monthly
basis so
Revenue paying attention to does your
Revenue go up every time you post a
video or is it more flat so this is a
candidate definitely for making more
content like these guys badly need to
make more content
um and then also your top videos based
off Revenue can you make into a series
foreign
traffic sources I obsess over traffic
sources you should start to obsess over
traffic sources where we want to be is
suggested being our number one traffic
Source the way to blow up a YouTube
channel is off of suggested use
which means you're showing up after
other people's videos
so the first game is ranking against
your own videos and we we did a
presentation on this a month ago showed
you the main ways of how to get
suggested it's it's critically important
because when you start showing up first
against your own videos and then against
other people's videos that's when
YouTube algorithm takes over and you
really start to blow up all your content
where if browse is your number one or
search is your number one it's going to
be a lot harder to really scale so
every month I would definitely pay
attention to on a channel level where
are my traffic sources what are they
looking at and is it improving
so it's it suggested fifth on your list
this month and is it you know fourth on
the list next month third on the list
are we moving in the right direction
because there's only so many views that
come from search and there's only so
many views that come from browse
or the most of the views the biggest
number of views that you'll be able to
get is from suggested so step number one
is showing up against your own channel
and
whenever uh I'm working with somebody
and I see that suggested becomes number
one as a traffic Source I get really
excited for them but I'm not seeing a
huge increase yet it doesn't matter it's
coming because suggested is number one
because before you can show up against
other people's channels you have to show
up against your own
so a quick hack is to go to Google or
YouTube Incognito load up your channel
play a video and see how many of your
own show up down the side
but this is the the Deep work to show
you hey here's how many views I'm
actually getting from suggested so every
month I would start to really pay
attention you guys can all go look at
your channels now look at past 28 days
and then look at where you were the
month before and the month before and
are we heading in the right direction
because this is the ultimate game to
really blow up our YouTube channels
and the last one I look at on a channel
level is frequency so how often are we
posting
uh I mean my channel we're posting every
single day
but when I'm looking at diving into
somebody else's Channel that's what I'm
paying attention to how often are we
posting content there's only so much you
can glean from the data if we haven't
posted a video in 11 months right so for
for most people the frequency needs to
be going up so
this is my general recommendation to
people so if you're not posting very
frequently at all get to once a week so
step number one is how do we get once a
week some content on the channel
and and that should be the goal whether
it's talking to the team or talking to
the owners or whoever like hey we need
to create our goal for June needs to be
to get a video week to come out on the
channel
because then that makes all this other
stuff more relevant more practical more
applicable
uh if you're already out once a week you
go three times a week
if you're ready at three times a week
you go we you go daily seven times a
week
Beyond this I don't I don't recommend
adding more content I'd recommend really
diving into which videos are performing
well for you
uh but it most people aren't here some
people have a goal to get here which is
great don't stress out once a week is
really just getting you in the game
so looking at this channel as an example
again where you see this little button
here that's that's when they uploaded a
video so you see everything spikes when
they upload a video so this is a channel
that is just crying for new content if
this was a flat if you look at my
channel it's it's
My Views don't really explode when I put
out a new video
because I'm doing it so frequently but
Their audience here is really crying for
new content
and so you have to you know that would
be my number one suggestion for this
channel
and for any of you who haven't posted in
a while
I get that it can be hard and maybe
discouraging or maybe feel like you
don't have the right strategy or know
what to do
um
part of it is just getting it in your
system to get out of video once a week
every week
figure out put it in your calendar put
in your schedule whether it's you doing
it whether you're you're working with an
Editor to help you
for any of this analytics stuff to be
meaningful to you you have to be at
least making one video a week at least I
really want you at three
I really really want you at seven but
let's get the let's get the one a week
let's get the one a week going so those
are some channel uh level analytics if
you want to see this full video as well
as trained live with me twice a month to
blow up your brand join the brand Linux
training program there's a link to join
right there next to me continue to
believe I'll see you there